if Amber rods resignation from cabinet
and party isn't damaging enough her
departing comments are incendiary and
provided glimpse behind the scenes of
Boris Johnson's government the former
work in pension secretary said the
sacking of 21 rebel MPs who had
previously defied the government was an
assault on decency and democracy and an
act of political vandalism Downing
Street said we are disappointed to learn
that amber has chosen to leave the
government and the party she was a
talented welfare minister but all
ministers who joined cabinet signed up
to leaving the EU on October the 31st
come what may
delivering on the referendum result as
the public were promised that has not
changed political figures from across
the spectrum quick to comment on the
resignation brexit party leader nigel
Faraj tweeted why did Boris give
ministerial posts so all these remain is
in the first place
confused thinking to say the least and
Sakhi Astana the shadow brexit secretary
tweeted Johnson government falling apart
he's being totally found out I think the
Conservative Party he's not just
drifting to the right it's absolutely
galloping to the right of British
politics becoming a right-wing rump it's
everything other than in name the brexit
party that's the reality of it and it's
under Boris Johnson stewardship Sky News
understands at the health secretary Matt
Hancock and culture secretary Nicky
Morgan both remain errs who've
criticized the No Deal brexit in the
past intent to stay on in their cabinet
roles
amber Rhodes resignation comes at a time
when the Prime Minister is being
buffeted from all directions
a new week in Parliament will see Boris
Johnson try again for a general election
he's likely to fail and his options are
running very low Boris Johnson Doe
remains undeterred the government source
said the Prime Minister still intends to
do whatever it takes to ensure that the
UK leaves the EU on October at the 31st
Nick Martin Sky News
Westminster